it is often said that the stories of
history are written by its victors or if
this is true what becomes of the
downtrodden and how can they ever hope
to aspire for something greater if
they're never told the stories of their
own glorious pasts ostensibly
I stand before you as a mere maker of
clothing but within the folds of ancient
fabrics modern textiles I have found a
higher calling through my work as a
designer I've discovered the importance
of providing representation for the
marginalized members of our society and
the importance of telling the most
vulnerable among us that they no longer
have to compromise themselves just so
they can fit in with an uncompromising
majority it turns out the fashion but
discipline many of us consider to be
trivial can actually be a powerful tool
for dismantling bias and bolstering the
self images of underrepresented
populations my interest in using design
as a vehicle for social change happens
to be a personal one as the Nigerian
American I know how easily the term
African can slip from being an ordinary
geographic descriptor to becoming a
pejorative for those of us from this
beautiful continent to be Africanist to
be inspired by culture and to be filled
with undying hope for the future so in
an attempt to shift the misguided
perceptions that many have about the
place of my birth I use design as a
means to tell stories stories about joy
stories about triumph stories about
perseverance all throughout the African
Diaspora I tell these stories as a
concerted effort to correct the
historical record because no matter
where any of us is from each of us has
been touched by the complicated
histories the Berber family is to a
foreign land these histories shaped the
way we view the world and they Mol's the
bias see as we carry around with us to
combat these biases my work draws
aesthetics from different parts of the
globe and crafts a narrative about the
importance of fighting for inclusive
by refashioning images from classic
European art marrying them with African
aesthetics I'm able to recast people of
color and rules of prominence providing
them with a degree of dignity they
didn't have in earlier times this
approach subverts the historically
accepted narrative of african
inferiority and it serves as inspiration
for people of color who've grown weary
have seen themselves depicted without
sophistication and without grace
each of these culture bending tapestries
becomes a tailored garment or a silk
scarf like the one I'm very confident ly
wearing right now and even when is
surrounded in a structure of European
classicism these narratives boldly extol
the merits of African empowerment in
this way the tools of the Masters become
master works to celebrate those who are
once too subservient this metaphor
extends beyond the realm of art and out
into the real world
whether worn by refugees or
world-changing entrepreneurs when people
are allowed the freedom to present
themselves in a manner that celebrates
their own unique identities the magical
thing happens we stand taller we're more
proud and self-aware because we're
presenting our true authentic selves and
those of us who around them in turn
become more educated more open more
tolerant but their different points of
view in this way the clothes that we
wear can be a great illustration of
diplomatic soft power the clothes that
we wear can service bridges between our
seemingly disparate cultures and so yeah
ostensibly I stand before you as a mere
maker of clothing well my work has
always been about more than fashion it
has become my purpose to rewrite the
cultural narratives so the people of
color can be seen in a new nuanced light
and so that we the proud children of
sub-saharan Africa can traverse the
globe while carrying ourselves with
pride
it was indeed true that the stories of
history were told by it's all Victor's
but I am of a new generation my work
speaks for those who will no longer let
their futures be dictated by a trouble
today we stand ready to tell our own
stories without compromise without
apologies but the question still remains
are you prepared for what you are about
to hear I hope you are because we are
coming regardless
[Applause]